[Music]
so we move to the cratchet house and
it's quiet very quiet the noisy little
cratchet were a still as statues in one
corner and sat looking up at Peter this
is the brother the older brother who had
a book before him the mother and her
daughters were engaged in sewing but
surely they were very quiet and he took
a child and set him in the midst of them
that's all we get it's one
line from well it could be actually any
of the synoptic gospels for example it
could be Mark
9:36 one little fragment of a Biblical
verse where it's Christ who takes a
child and puts him in the middle of them
uh of of his Apostles well on the one
hand that makes an intuitive sense in
this novel this is the house where Tiny
Tim lived and he as we will shortly find
is dead there's something kind of
there's a kind of Mel dramatic pathos
about referencing Christ putting him
there amidst them that all makes sense
but listen to the way that it
continues where had Scrooge heard those
words we're hearing his very thoughts
all of a sudden right he had not dreamed
them the boy must have read them out as
he and the spirit crossed the threshold
why did he not go on so Scrooge actually
has this desire to hear the rest of the
passage and that accuse us readers also
to think about the rest of the passage
now it may be that you hear this and
don't actually know what the rest of the
passage is but in the Victorian period
there's a lot greater biblical literacy
than what we have today most of them I I
would guess would be able to fill in
something for the next the next part of
this verse I'll do that for you uh in
case in case you can't so the line that
Peter read was he took a child and set
him in the midst of them stop Scrooge
wondering what is the next thing the
next thing is this whosoever shall
receive one of such children in my name
receiveth
me that's the next thing that Christ
says and why is that
important I would suggest
first we're meant to supply this
ourselves just as I just did uh in the
sil
of our own hearts or minds and with it
to see that when a child is placed into
the midst it's actually God himself um
coming in amongst you in the middle of
this book this verse means so much
because this whole novel has been a
succession of children of poor ones of
little ones of little things even right
that are smaller than people like Calves
or or dead bodies it's uh you know
apples and onions and and and all these
things but it's a succession of little
ones coming to Scrooge also coming to us
by the way and each of those as we see
in this pivotal moment is actually a
sight of divine
encounter that's the secret and the
secret energy the secret mysterious
power and Presence at the heart of this
whole little
Nolla the Divine entering time this is
after all the mystery of Christmas this
is what the Incarnation
[Music]
is